Speaker 1: Despite claiming that he never thinks
about Ron DeSantis failed, former President Donald
Trump is clearly obsessed with Ron DeSantis,
and that obsession is starting to become very,
very unhealthy. It is abundantly clear and it
is supported by the fact that Donald Trump sees
Ron DeSantis as potentially his most powerful
challenger in the 2024 Republican primary. Now,
Ron DeSantis still hasn't announced that he is
running. We talked earlier in the show about
why that might be and when his announcement
might be coming, if indeed he plans to make
that announcement. Donald Trump is posting daily
to his platform Truth Social about Ron DeSantis.
I hope that anybody who is planning on following
the 2024 election is prepared for more than a year
of what we saw over the last four days. Take a
look at some of these childish and ridiculous
posts from the failed former president who's
nearly 80 years old. This is not a kid that
we're talking about. First, posting about the
size of Ron DeSantis is. Crowd quote. Very small
crowds for Ron to sanctimonious in Iowa. He's
against capital F farmers. Social Security and
medicare. So why would people show up other than
capital F fake stories from the capital F fake
capital N news. The random capitalization and
the lies both staples of Donald Trump's posts,
as we talked about before attacking DeSantis on
Social Security and Medicare, is a little shaky
given Trump's own history with submitting federal
budgets that would cut Social Security. Okay.
Then Trump goes on to comparing his book to Ron
DeSantis book posting, quote, Summon the fake
news or falsely stating that Ron Too sanctimonious
book is doing as well as letters to Trump. My new
book. This is fake news in that letters doesn't
even come out until April 25th. Ron has groups
buying his book in order to inflate sales. And in
fact, on the first day, his book was already 30%
discounted. Letters to Trump has much different
pricing and is a coffee table book. The so-called
stars corresponded with me. You'll love it.
Preorder the book. So couple of different things
there. Of course, Donald Trump just obsessed with
comparing the size of all of his things to that
of Ron DeSantis. And Trump is not mentioning
that Don Jr's book also benefited from groups
buying the book. This is actually a really common
thing. It's particularly common on the right,
although maybe it does happen on the left as
well. But when large right wing figures whose
followers barely read, I mean, let's be let's be
really, really honest with each other here. Do
you think the average Don Jr follower reads books?
Where would you put the over under on the number
of books the average Don Jr follower reads and I
hate folks that this is. It sounds so a Leo but
David reading over come on. Trump himself hasn't
read a book in his adult life and we're supposed
to pretend Don's while Don Jr's followers
read books. Don Jr's book benefited greatly
from people groups buying the book and then giving
it out when Don Jr speaks and this sort of thing.
Okay, then Trump continuing to be obsessed with
Ron DeSantis posts the results to a meaningless
online poll about 2024, where 15,000 people
clicked a button online and said they preferred
DeSantis. They preferred Trump to DeSantis
by 2 to 1. Now, I believe Trump is winning,
but Trump just posting garbage polls and then
Trump posting, quote, Ron does sanctimonious,
totally caved in his public relations inspired
battle with Disney. That's the only reason he
went after them in the first place to show Mr.
Tough Guy. Disney maintained complete exemption
from property and sales tax, tax free bonds and
their incredible fast track permitting. They
also gave big political contributions to the
Sanctus. The whole thing is a capital H hoax.
They probably work together to make them look
like a fighter. Read Rick Vogelsang Preeminent
authority on Disney. I could keep going back to
last week, but I won't. This might be the most
childish and ridiculous primary that we ever
see. And meanwhile, on the Democratic side,
there may be no primary if Joe Biden runs for
reelection, which some people say isn't good.
There are people on the left who say forget about
its impact on the general. The Democratic Party
should have a real primary. If there are people
challenging Joe Biden. There should be a real
primary and there should be debates and so on and
so forth there. I understand that perspective and
we're going to talk about that more maybe a little
bit later this week or maybe once we we hear from
a couple other candidates who plan to declare.
But Trump obsessed unhealthily with Ron DeSantis.